I'd like you to keep getting more practice using long division, so let's do
this problem as well. This time we're starting out with x cubed minus 1, and
I'd like us to divide that by x minus 1. How do you write this using long
division though? Well, you might think it would be this way, like before all
I've done is taken the thing we want to divide, written our lovely long
division surrounding it. And then written the thing we want to divide it by
outside. This isn't going to work quite right in this situation of this
polynomial though. Here's why. We only have two terms here, but this is a cubic
polynomial. With other cubic's we've worked with, we've had a term for every
single power starting with the highest power and descending. This time we don't
have an x squared term and we don't have an x term. In order to do long
division properly though, we still need to leave slots for those terms In the
expression that we start out with. Instead we're going to need to write the
polynomial like this. Note that by writing 0x squared and 0x for the x squared
and x terms, we're not changing the value of the original expression we had
underneath the division sign. But we are still leaving room for the terms of
these powers. Now we're in great shape to do our division. So let's do it!
Please write your final answer in this box.